NOW IN SESSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM THE SERGEANT AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND
BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN ARAMBULA BAKER. BERMAN
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON CARILLO
SERVAN TEMAS TRIAL CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DAHLE.
DALY.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY. GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
CHOLERA
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI. NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH
STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER. WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
TODAY'S INVOCATION. WHICH WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REVEREND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
ON A GLOBAL SCALE IT SEEMS THAT
THERE IS MORE SABER RATTLING NOW
AND WE HAVE FELT IN DECADES.
THE FEELING OF INSTABILITY GROWS
WITH EVERY THREAT VEILED AND
OTHERWISE.
WHEN THE ATOMIC BOMB EXPLODED
OVER THE CITY OF NAGASAKI.
ALL LIFE NEAR THE GROUND ZERO
WAS INCINERATED WITHOUT A TRACE.
A FEW HUNDRED YARDS FROM GROUND
ZERO.
HUMAN BONES BLEACHED WHITE WERE
FOUND SCATTERED WITHIN THE
DEVASTATION.
HIGASHI BATHROOM TEMPLE ANOTHER
SAKE. HAS AN UNDERGROUND
COLUMBARIUM WITH YOURS AND
YOURS.
STILL HOLDING THE UNIDENTIFIED
MOANS OF ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
VICTIMS.
ABOVE THIS COLUMBARIUM ISN'T IS
INSCRIBED STONE MONUMENT.
THE INSCRIPTION IS A GENTLE
REMINDER FOR ALL HUMANITY.
IT READS HE SANG HE KAKU.
THE FREEZING INDICATES THAT THIS
IS NOT A MESSAGE TO BE SHOUTED.
OR EVEN SPOKEN ALOUD.
IT IS MORE PERSONAL THOUGHT WE
MIGHT QUIETLY WHISPERED TO
OURSELVES.
IT WOULD READ.
I HAVE NO NEED FOR WAR OR
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
IN A. IT IS AS IF THE BONES
THEMSELVES ARE SAYING. WAR IS
NOT THE WAY.
AS MAHATMA GANDHI ENCOURAGED.
THERE IS NO PATH TO PEACE.
PEACE IS THE PATH.
IT ISN'T NURTURING LOVING
KINDNESS AND HARMONY. THAT WE
EACH CAN BECOME THE PATH. THAT
IS PEACE.
NUMBER ONE WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE FLAG
SALUTE TODAY'S FLAG SALUTE WILL
BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DOLLY.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
NATION
THERE ARE.
PHYSICAL.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY
SECOND TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE DAHLE
MET AT NINE A. M. ON A LAWYER
FOR MISTER CALDERON MOVES TO
MISTER DALY SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
SPEAK ON IN GERMAN AND MEMORY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE THE
FOLLOWING.
BILLS FOR THEIR APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH HEARING PENDING WE
REFERRAL FROM THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE
FRIEDMAN AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
TING AND A. B. THIRTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN KALLIO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE OTHERS PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
I DON'T MAYBE TWO AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN COOLEY ITEM ONE SIXTEEN
AB TWENTY TWO A SIX CHEN. ITEM
ONE SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY FIVE OBERNOLTE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER TO THE FOLLOWING
NINE TWENTY THURMAN FROM THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. AB THIRTY FIFTY
TWO CHEN FROM THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
AND SP FOUR NINETY FIVE I'D ACT
FROM THE GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONAL IS ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING ITEMS FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND RE
REFER THEM TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ITEM SEVENTY NINE AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THREE BONTA.
AN ITEM EIGHTY THREE. AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SIX CHEN THE BILL'S
SHOULD HAVE BEEN KEY TO FISCAL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THE ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND RECORDED IN THE JOURNAL
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY PLEASE
GIVE YOUR UTMOST ATTENTION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE MISTER
STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ONE HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
THAT SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE
WAS FORMED AND SINCE THAT TIME
THEY HAVE ACTUALLY SAVED OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES. AND
CREATED SIXTY SIX PARKS AND
OTHER PRESERVES.
TO PROTECT THE REDWOOD IN ITS
NATURAL RANGE ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
SO TODAY WE HAVE A COUPLE
MEMBERS OF THE STATE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE.
SAM HARDER WHO IS THE CEO AND
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS OF PUBLIC FUNDING
SHOWING THAT THE SILVER WHO ARE
HERE WITH US TODAY.
I BELIEVE THAT THERE UP IN THE
GALLERY THEY COULD STANDS.
UNLIKE OTHER THEY ARE.
GIVE THEM A WARM WELCOME AND
CONGRATULATE THEM ON A HUNDRED
YEARS.
THERE'S A PRESERVING SOME OF OUR
MOST ICON.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS I WILL ASK
YOU ALL TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS WE HAVE A VERY VERY
SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION AND I
WOULD.
QUEST THAT EVERYBODY PLEASE TAKE
THEIR SEATS AT THIS TIME.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES YOUR
RECOGNIZE FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLINS DESK
MEMBERS I REQUEST YOUR PATIENTS
WE WILL RETURN TO THIS ITEM
MOMENTARILY.
OKAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. AND
MEMBERS.
IT IS A GREAT HONOR THAT I
INTRODUCE PHOTOS WENT BACK TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR THIS MORNING.
WHAT IS WHAT? BORN THE LOTUS
GLAD UP AND NONE THIS.
ON APRIL TENTH NINETEEN THIRTY
IN BOSTON NEW MEXICO.
THE PROUD DAUGHTER OF ONE COULD
NOT THIS IN THE LOT IS WHAT
THOSE MOTHER.
YEAH THAT NONE THIS.
VOTERS WENT FOUND HER CALLING AS
AN ORGANIZER WORLD WHILE SERVING
IN THE LEADERSHIP.
OF THE STOCKTON CHAPTER THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE ORGANIZATION.
AND LATER FOUNDED THE
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
ASSOCIATION.
SHE SET UP VOTER REGISTRATION
DRIVES.
PRESS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PROVIDE
IMPROVEMENTS
AND HAS BEEN.
AN ABSOLUTE LEADER IN EVERY
ASPECT OF CIVIL.
RIGHTS.
THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY.
DURING THIS EARLY TIME THE LOTUS
WEB THAT MATT.
SO IT'S NOT JOB IS A FELLOW CSO
OFFICIAL. WHO LATER BECAME ITS
DIRECTOR?
IN NINETEEN SIXTY TWO
LOCOMOTIVES WEAPONS HAS NOT
CHAVEZ LOBBIED TO HAVE THE CSO
EXPAND ITS EFFORTS TO HELP THE
FARMWORKERS.
WHAT THE ORGANIZATION WAS ONLY
FOCUSED ON URBAN ISSUES?
AS A RESULT SAYS THAT CHAVEZ AND
THE VOTERS WHAT THE RESIGNED
FROM THE CSO. AND CO FOUNDED THE
NATIONAL FARM WORKERS
ASSOCIATION.
THE LORD IS WHAT THOSE
ORGANIZING SKILLS OR EAST
CENTRAL TO THE GROWTH OF THE
ASSOCIATION.
THE TO MADE A GREAT TEAM SETS UP
TRAVIS THE DYNAMIC LEADER IN
SPEAKER.
AND THE OTHERS WHETHER THAT THE
SKILLED ORGANIZER TOUGH
NEGOTIATOR AND LATER ONE OF ITS
MOST VOCAL SPEAKERS.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THE
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS ORGANIZING
COMMITTEE.
AND THE NATIONAL FARM WORKERS
ASSOCIATION COMBINED TO BECOME
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS
ORGANIZING COMMITTEE LATER KNOWN
AS THE UNITED FARM WORKERS.
THE LAWYERS WENT THAT ALSO WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE INACTIVE
MEANT OF THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE.
THIS WAS THE FIRST LAW OF ITS
KIND IN THE UNITED STATES.
GRANTING FARM WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA THE RIGHT TO
COLLECTIVELY ORGANIZE AND
BARGAIN FOR BETTER WAGES.
LOW'S WET THAT HAS BEEN AN
ADVOCATE FOR THE ENTIRE FAMILY.
SHE HAS MOVED SHE HAS
RECOMMENDED THE ENTIRE FAMILIES
PARTICIPATION IN THE MOVEMENT.
BUT THIS LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
WAS BECAUSE IT WAS THE ENTIRE
FAMILY. THE MOTHER'S THE FATHERS
THE MEN THE WOMEN THE CHILDREN
WHO WORK TOGETHER.
IN THE FIELDS PICKING PLANNING
AND HOEING.
A PRACTICE OF NON VIOLENCE WAS
ONE. THAT SHE ADVOCATED FOR
THROUGHOUT THE MOVEMENT.
SHOULD BE NOTED THOUGH THAT IN
NINETEEN.
EIGHTY EIGHT.
HER LIFE.
WAS PUT IN JEOPARDY.
BECAUSE OF A PARTICULAR
INCIDENT.
AND I HOPE YOU ALL WILL READ UP
ON IT.
FIFTY EIGHT YEARS OLD THREE OF
HER RIBS WERE FRACTURED.
RUPTURED SPLEEN.
BECAUSE OF HER INVOLVEMENT IN
THE MOVEMENT.
MANY OF US HAVE HEARD THE PHRASE
SEIZE UP WHETHER.
NOT ONLY WHERE THEY THE MOVEMENT
UNITE FARMWORKERS MOVEMENT BUT
IN ALL OF SOCIETY.
OFTENTIMES PEOPLE THINK THAT IT
WAS OUR FRIEND SO SUCH OBVIOUS
WE'RE GOING THE PHRASE.
BUT IT WAS NOT IT WAS THE LAWS
WENT BACK A GOING THAT PHRASE
WHICH TO THIS DAY IS REPEATED.
REPEATEDLY.
BECAUSE OF WHAT IT MEANS YES WE
CAN.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
PRESIDENTE BARACK OBAMA BESTOWED
THE LOTUS WENT THAT WITH THE
MOST PRESTIGIOUS AWARD. THE
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM.
THE HIGHEST CIVILIAN AWARD IN
THE UNITED STATES.
SHE WAS ALSO INDUCTED INTO THE
CALIFORNIA HALL OF FAME IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
THAT'S A VERY YOUNG EIGHTY FOUR
YEAR OLD.
THE LOTUS WEB THAT CONTINUES TO
WORK TIRELESSLY.
YOU NO IT SAYS EIGHTY EIGHT BUT
I SAID.
I WILL MY STAFF TO DO THAT THE
MATH BUT
OKAY EIGHTY EIGHT.
I'M EVEN PROUDER OF HER.
THE YOUNG AGE OF EIGHTY EIGHT
THE LAWS WEBER CONTINUES TO WORK
TIRELESSLY DEVELOPING LEADERS IN
ADVOCATING FOR THE WORKING POOR.
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
AS FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF THE
LOTUS WITHOUT FOUNDATION.
TRAVELS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND ADVOCATES IN CAMPAIGNS AND
ADVOCATES FOR LEGISLATION.
SUPPORT QUALITY AND THE FANS
CIVIL RIGHTS.
SHE CONTINUES TO BE A VOICE FOR
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
PUBLIC POLICY.
BELOW IS WHAT THE CONTINUES TO
LECTURE AND SPEAK OUT IN A
VARIETY OF SOCIAL ISSUES
INVOLVING IMMIGRATION. INCOMING
IN THE QUALITY AND THE RIGHTS OF
WOMEN CHILDREN. THE MOST
MARGINALIZED NOT VENUS.
SHE TEACHES THE CONCEPT OF
PERSONAL POWER THAT NEEDS TO BE
COUPLED WITH RESPONSIBILITY AND
COOPERATION TO CREATE THE
CHANGES NEEDED TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF THE WORKING POOR.
THE MOTORS WEBER HAS BEEN
HONORED FOR HER WORK AS A FIERCE
ADVOCATE
IF FARMWORKERS IMMIGRANTS OF THE
WORKING POOR. AND WOMEN FOR
YEARS AND YEARS.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE MANY WHO
HAVE RECEIVED LOTS OF HONORS AND
WILL WE SEE THE PHOTO. IT IS ALL
MAN.
AND THEN THERE IS THE LOTUS WITH
THEM.
OFTENTIMES OR USE AFRAID BEEN
BEAT THE ONE THING I LOVE OKAY
THIS BLESSED IS HE AMONG WOMEN.
BUT HERE IS BEEN THE BACK END
BUT A LOVE SONG THAT IS BLESSED
TO SEE AMONG THE MAN.
THE LOTUS WEB THAT HAS BROKEN
THE GLASS CEILINGS SHE'S PUSH
THE FRONTIERS OF WOMEN'S
LEADERSHIP AND AS PEEVED PARA
FOR OTHER WOMEN AND GIRLS TO
FOLLOW IN HER FOOTSTEPS. AND
BECOME THOSE FUTURE LEADERS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I'D LIKE TO
NOW ASK OUR SPEAKER. ANTHONY
RENDON TO SHARE A FEW WORDS
BEFORE WE INTRODUCE OUR GUEST OF
HONOR.
ACTUALLY WE ARE FIRST GOING TO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN.
VERY MUCH MADAM. SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'D ALSO WANT TO RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE DOORS WHERE TOUGH BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW IF I SHOULD NEVER
SAID BUT SHE IS A STOCK TONY AND
SHE IS FROM STOCKTON SHE DOESN'T
WANT LEGACY IN STOCK AND. BEGAN
HER WORK THERE WAS A SCHOOL
TEACHER THEIR CHILDREN THERE AYE
AND IS ONE OF MANY IN A VERY
LARGE FAMILY.
SHE IS OF THE PRIDE OF STOCKTON
TO COMES BACK FREQUENTLY STILL
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO
A LOT OF WORK WITH HER ON HER
FOUNDATION I KNOW HER BECAUSE
HER SIBLINGS. HER NIECES AND HER
NEPHEWS SHE LEAVES AN INCREDIBLE
LEGACY IN THE CITY OF STOCKTON
CHOOSE ONE OF OUR OWN AND
CERTAINLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT HER
LIFE'S WORK.
AROUND JUSTICE AROUND EQUITY
AROUND A RAISING US ALL UP YOU
CAN SEE THAT IF YOU ENGAGE IN
THAT KIND OF WORK WITH THE
PASSION THAT THE LAWYERS WERE TO
HAS. A DEDICATED HER LIFE ENTIRE
LIFE TO YOU TOO COULD DISCOVER
THE FOUNTAIN OF YOUTH.
THANK YOU. MISTER SPEAKER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THANK
YOU MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO JOIN A
LIVING LEGEND WHETHER SHE'S
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOESN'T REALLY MATTER.
JUSTICE WHETHER IT'S LGBT.
Q. ISSUES SO WHETHER IT'S.
HOST TO. HOST.
OF USED TISSUES
I ANGELA DAVIS ONCE DESCRIBED
HER AS.
AT HER LIFE IS ONE THAT'S LIVED
INTO SEXUALLY.
AND IN THAT LIFE TO OR IS REMAIN
CONSTANT IN FIGHTING TO A POWER
THE POWERLESS.
AS SHE ONCE SAID HERSELF EVERY
MOMENT IS. EVERY MOMENT AS AN
ORGANIZING OPPORTUNITY.
EVERY PERSON A POTENTIAL
ACTIVIST
AND EVERY MINUTE A CHANCE TO
CHANGE THE WORLD.
SO I WANT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT YEARS AND.
.
AND A YOU'RE EIGHTY EIGHT YEARS
OF TRYING TO CHANGE THE WORLD
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIXTY WITH
THE MOMENTS TWENTY SIX OF SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTY FOURTEEN
WITH THE MOMENT SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SIX WITH AMENDMENTS
TWENTY SIX FORTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS. TWENTY THREE NINETY
THREE SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTEEN
NINETY NINE.
SEVENTEEN NINETY ONE EIGHTEEN
SIXTY ONE NINETEEN FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIVE POINT
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
ELEVEN POINT THREE SEVENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SIX TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
FORTY FOR. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE SIXTY ONE
TWENTY SIX SIXTY TWENTY SEVEN OH
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY TWO
THIRTY SEVENTEEN. TWENTY BY
THIRTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED AT THE MOMENT. NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS WE
WANT SEVENTY FIVE AT THE
MINISTRY AFFORD FIFTY EIGHT WITH
THE MEMONS. THIRTY OH SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY FORTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS NINETEEN FIFTY
TWO WITH THE MEMONS TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SIX WITH AMENDMENTS.
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS THIRTY SEVENTY SIX
AMENDMENTS NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
OF THE AMENDMENTS TO EIGHT FIFTY
NINE WITH AMENDMENTS. NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TO A FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS MADE USE
OF THE TO THE MOMENTS. PLACE
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS TO A SEVEN NINETY
SEVEN WITH A DEMONSTRATE SEVEN
FORTY FOURTH AMENDMENTS MADE TO
US ABOUT AMENDMENTS
MEMBERS WE HAVE BUSINESS TO
CONDUCT ON THE FLOOR.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION.
TO.
TO YOUR COLLEAGUES MOVING NOW TO
ITEM FIFTY SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY NINE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
FORTY NINE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
DALY AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION.
THANK YOU A SUMMER DEL YOUR
RIGHT DALY ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
ON OCTOBER FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
SEVERAL OFF DUTY ORANGE COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFFS.
RESPONDED.
DURING THE MASS SHOOTING IN LAS
VEGAS.
AS IS THEIR TRAINING AND THEIR
DUTY.
OFFICERS FROM OTHER
JURISDICTIONS ANSWERED THAT CALL
AS WELL.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THESE
DEPUTIES.
S. PEACE OFFICERS WERE INJURED.
UNLIKE REGULAR EMPLOYEES PEACE
OFFICERS ARE ON DUTY TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN.
EVEN THEY WERE WHEN THEY ARE NOT
ON A SCHEDULED SHIFT.
I THINK MOST REASONABLE PERSONS
WILL AGREE.
BUT THESE OFFICERS ARE ENTITLED
TO BENEFITS.
THEY TOOK ACTION AS THEIR SWORN
OATH DEMANDS AND SOME OF THEM
SUSTAINED INJURIES.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT BRAVE
PEACE OFFICERS AND OTHERS IN THE
FUTURE RECEIVE THE BENEFITS TO
WHICH THEY ARE ENTITLED AS A
RESULT OF BEING INJURED ON THE
JOB. THAT IS ALL THIS BILL
PROVIDES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MEMBERS TODAY I JOIN US COAUTHOR
OF AB SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
ANA FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE FORWARD.
LAST YEAR SEVERAL OFF DUTY
POLICE OFFICERS FROM CALIFORNIA
SPRANG INTO ACTION.
DURING THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTING
INCLUDING OFFICERS FROM MY
COMMUNITY AND SOMEBODY NO
COUNTY.
THESE OFFICERS ARE SWORN TO
PROTECT US ALL IN CALIFORNIA YET
THEY BRAVELY ANSWERED THE CALL
FOR HELP IN NEVADA.
WE SHOULD ENSURE THESE PEACE
OFFICERS AND ANY OTHER OFFICERS
INJURED. OUT OF OUR STATE WERE
PERFORMING THEIR DUTY PROTECT.
OUR ENTITLED WORKMEN'S
COMPENSATION BENEFITS AT HOME
ALSO RESPECT AFTER OUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER BRO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ANAHEIM FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
UNFORTUNATE THIS STEM FROM AN
INCIDENT WHERE.
PEACE OFFICERS ARE OUT OF STATE
AND THE COUNTY OF ORDERS TO DIED
THEIR CLAIMS SO WE NEED TO STAND
UP FOR THESE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS TO MAKE SURE. IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN THREAT OR
THEY DO NOT HESITATE BUT THEY
STEP IN AND SAVE LIVES SO THANKS
AGAIN MY* MAN I'M ASKED FOR
A VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AYE MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS OF
THE AUTHOR AS WELL AS I I USED
TO WORK FOR THE COUNTY AND.
THIS IS A RIGHT FULL AND I JUST
THING TO DO OF FOR OUR BRETHREN.
AND I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE HIM
BRING THIS FORWARD AND I'M VERY
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A VERY FINE
BUILT ON TOP OF ALL THE OTHER
RATIONALES FOR. I THINK.
IF YOU ARE CALIFORNIA IN AND A
CONCERT IN LAS VEGAS NEVADA.
IF YOU ARE THERE YOU PROBABLY
KNOW THAT THERE ARE CALIFORNIANS
THERE AS WELL.
SO ON SO EVERY EVERY LEVEL THIS
IS ONE WHERE IT IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO THEY TAKE THEIR OATH
TO
ATTACKED AND TO SERVE. WHY?
ASSUME THAT THEY WOULD PULL BACK
VERTICALLY KNOWING THAT THEY'RE
NOT THE ONLY CALIFORNIA'S
PRISON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER I ALSO IN MY VOICE WITH
OTHERS WHO HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN
AND THANK THE AUTHOR TO BRING
THIS GOOD SENSIBLE LEGISLATION
ARE BEFORE US TODAY AS A FORMER
POLICE OFFICER. WE ARE POLICE
OFFICER TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK. AND THAT
CONTINUE TO BE TRUE WHETHER
YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA OR LAS
VEGAS NEVADA AND CERTAINLY IF
YOU ARE PROTECTING LIFE ON THE
STATE'S TO PROTECT YOU AND
SUPPORT YOU IN TERMS OF
WORKMEN'S COMPENSATION. AND TO
HEAR THAT SOME ARE FELLOW
OFFICERS WHO SPRUNG INTO ACTION
TO HELP SAVE LIVES AND MINIMIZE
THE TRAGEDIES.
AND THE GALAXIES THAT TOOK
PLACE END OF LOS VEGAS ON ONE
THEIR HEROES THEY SHOULD BE
COMMENDED BUT WE SHOULD ALSO
STAND BY THOSE INDIVIDUALS SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK NOT A VOTE. ON
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
NINE I THINK THE AUTHOR OF A
BRING IT BEFORE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ACOSTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
RISE.
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY NINE I HAD A LOT OF
FRIENDS LIKE I'M SURE MANY OF US
DID THERE WERE ACTUALLY THERE ON
THE GROUND. A ONE OF THEM WAS A
POLICE OFFICER'S WIFE AND
DAUGHTER AND FRIENDS THEY HAD TO
RUN FOR THEIR LIVES. BUT WHAT
DID HAPPEN IS SEVERAL AYE AYE
SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS FROM MY
DISTRICT.
WE DID RUN TOWARD THE GUNFIRE
OR TOWARD THE SEC THE VICTIM'S.
TO AID THEM ONE OF THEM WAS
ACTUALLY INJURED. AND WE WE YOU
KNOW THEY DIDN'T STOP AND THINK
FOR A MOMENT.
GEE WHERE AM I AM I AM NEVADA
THERE AND IN MY CALIFORNIA NO
THEY SIMPLY REACTED BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THEIR TRAINING. IS
ALL ABOUT AND WHEN THEY'RE
TRAINING KICKED IN THEY WENT TO
AID AND HELP THEIR FELLOW MAN
AND I THINK WE CAN DO NOTHING.
NOTHING LESS THAN THIS MEASURE
AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S A
AND THEN ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MISSED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THE STRONG
SHOWING OF BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
FOR A VERY IMPORTANT BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELE THE VOTES SIXTY
ONE.
I KNOW ZERO.
THE MOTION PASSES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I MOVE
TO RE REFER ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
THREE AB TWENTY THREE NINETY ONE
HARPER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER WALDRON YOUR
RECOGNIZE WE OBJECT TO THAT
MOTION THEN ASK FOR ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS MISTER CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE MISS
WALDRON IS ACTING FOR A NO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON IT'S
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF WALDRON IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BOTTOM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROWING TALLY THE VOTES.
I FORTY ONE AT NO TWENTY TWO.
THE MOTION CARRIES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM FIFTY EIGHT
AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED BOTTOM
QUICKLY THREE.
AS SOME PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED BY SUMMING UP.
IT'S YOU AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETICS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
CHECK THEM SPEAKER AB TWENTY A
HUNDRED WELL AB RECOGNITION AND
TREATMENT OF HEAT. HEAT RELATED
ILLNESS TO THE FIRST AID
TRAINING FOR HIGH SCHOOL COACHES
AND TRAINERS.
TO MAKE* TO THE TRAINING AS
EASY AS POSSIBLE THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW TO TRAINING TO BE
FULFILLED BY A FREE ONLINE
COURSE.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEDICARE QUIZ OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY TWO AYE
VOTES NO ZERO VOTES VOTES THE
MOTION THE. MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS FIFTY NINE THROUGH SIXTY
ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM SIXTY TWO AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY MATTER QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE THAT
BY SELLING
HER WEBER AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN
TO PRESENT.
SO MEMBER ROBERT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND UP MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY. A BILL
RECOGNIZING THE HUMANITY OF
WOMEN IN COURT IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY RESTORES
DIGNITY TO INCARCERATED WOMEN
AND REDUCES FURTHER TRAUMA BUT
ONE PROHIBITING MALE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS FROM BEING
IN VIEW OF OR PAT DOWN SEARCH IN
WOMEN. WHO ARE INCARCERATED OR
ENTER INTO AN AREA WHERE
INCARCERATED WOMEN ARE IN A
STATE OF UNDRESS DOING IT AND
DOING SUCH A SHOWER ROOMS AND
BATHROOMS? THIS BILL PUTS INTO
LAW SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS THAT
ESTABLISHED BY THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS AND THE CD R. C.
POLICIES. THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION IS SPONSORED BY HAS
TECH CUT FIFTY AND THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND
SUPPORTED BY THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS. THE CALIFORNIA OF.
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE AND PRISON
LAW OFFICERS A IT IS IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE HUMANITY OF WOMEN
WHO BEHIND BARS AND CONTINUE
MOVING FORWARD WITH COMPASSION
AND TREATMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ME AYE VOTE ON TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY. AND WISH
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER WORK
ON THIS BILL.
THE BILL IS A SIMPLE AND
STRAIGHT FORWARD FIX TO PROTECT
FEMALE PRISONERS FROM THE TRAUMA
OF BEING PATTED DOWN BY MALE
GUARDS.
BECOMING INCARCERATED THAT MAY
MEAN THAT A WOMAN GIVES UP HER
FREEDOM FOR THE PRESCRIBED TIME
OF HER SENTENCE.
WHAT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU
SHOULD BE FORCED TO GIVE UP HER
DIGNITY?
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SOME MEMBER LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
YEAH THANK YOU MEMBERS MADAM
SPEAKER AND.
AND MEMBERS.
I I'D LIKE TO STAND HERE IS A A
PROUD CO AUTHOR TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY WHICH WILL CODIFY STANDARD
RESPECT BETWEEN INCARCERATED
WOMEN. A CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION OF HAS EXISTING
POLICIES IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT.
PEOPLE OFFICERS CONDUCT PAT DOWN
SEARCHES OF FEMALE INMATES AND
THIS BILL SIMPLY PRESERVES THOSE
PROTECTIONS. AS A STANDARD OF
STATE LAW AND I ENCOURAGE YOUR
YOUR SUPPORT NOT VOTE.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE VOTE FOR AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN
THE RUN. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM SIXTY THREE AND SIXTY FOUR
PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM SIXTY FIVE AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE MATTER QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE BY SOME
REYES AND.
S. WASTE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE STRAIGHTFORWARD
MEASURE REQUIRES. AN APPLICANT
FOR THE RENEWAL OF A HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITY PERMIT.
SUBMIT FOR REVIEW AT LEAST TWO
YEARS REPORTS EXPLORATION
PERMITS THAT EXPIRE AFTER JULY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
IN ADDITION THE BILL REQUIRES A
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL TO POST ON ITS WEBSITE
AN ESTIMATED TIMELINE OF KEY
MILESTONES IN THE REVIEW
PROCESS.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS ALSO
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE
VOTE.
THINK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULING TELLY DEVOTES I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM SIXTY SIX ACR TO AWAIT
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TILL EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR CURRY AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO CALVARY WINDS DOWN TO EARTH
MONTH THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR CURRY OR RECOGNIZE THINK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT ACR TO
VOTE TWO ZERO EIGHT THIS
RESOLUTION DECLARES THE MONTH OF
APRIL AS.
CALIFORNIA WINES DOWN TO EARTH
MONTH.
THIS YEAR MARKS THE SEVENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ANNUAL DOWN
TO EARTH MONTH CELEBRATION WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE SUSTAINABLE
LEADERSHIP OF CALIFORNIA
WINERIES AND WINE GRAPE GROWERS.
THE PURPOSE OF THE DOWN TO EARTH
MONTH IS TO ENGAGE THE CONSUMERS
POLICY LEADERS THE MEDIA AND THE
WINE INDUSTRY. THROUGH IT YET
ECO FRIENDLY EVENTS SUCH AS.
EARTH DAY FESTIVALS VINEYARD
HIKES FOOD WINE FESTIVALS AND
ECO TOURS.
THE CALIFORNIA WINE INDUSTRY IS
WORKING HARD TO NOT ONLY PRODUCE
THE BEST TASTING WINES IN THE
WORLD BUT ALSO TO MAKE THEM THE
MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY.
I AM VERY PROUD OF ALL THE WORK
THAT THEY HAVE DONE I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO DRIVE
OVER TO MY DISTRICT. THIS MONTH
TO TAKE PART IN WHAT TO TAKE
PART IN DOWN TO EARTH MONTH.
INVENTS IN THIS NAPA IN THE NAPA
VALLEY SONO MONO COUNTY SO SOON
VALLEY. LAKE COUNTY OR RIGHT
DOWN THE ROAD TO CLARKSBURG. I
LIKE TO OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS ANY RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AS A
MEMBER OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON WINE I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ACR CHOI. WHICH WOULD NAME
APRIL AS CALIFORNIA WINES DOWN
TO EARTH MONTH.
WIND IS AN INTEGRAL COMPONENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND HAS
BECOME SYNONYMOUS WITH OUR
STATE.
WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CALIFORNIA WINE.
WOULD NOT BE WHERE IT IS TODAY
WITHOUT FARMER INVESTMENTS AND
THE HARD WORK PUT IN BY THEIR
EMPLOYEES WHO HARVEST AND HELP
CREATE A DELICIOUS COMMODITY.
THAT MANY OF US ENJOY.
WIND BRINGS FAMILIES AND FRIENDS
TOGETHER BUT IT ALSO HELPS PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE.
CALIFORNIA WINES CONTRIBUTE TO
QUALITY JOBS AS WELL AS TAX IN
TOURISM DOLLARS TO NATIONAL
STATE AND LOCAL ECONOMIES.
IN FACT IN MY DISTRICT WHICH I
JUST LEARNED TODAY THERE IS AN
ANNUAL WINE ECONOMIC ACTIVITY OF
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS PROVIDING OVER
NINETY FIVE MILLION IN ANNUAL
WAGES AND BENEFITS. WHILE
EMPLOYING ONE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE FULL TIME
JOBS.
SOME OF THESE JOBS ARE PROVIDED
BY BUSINESSES LIKE RED RICH
VINEYARDS IN GLENDORA THE SALTON
OUR WINE AND CHEESE PARTY IN
MONROVIA.
REBEL WINERY AND BRING COMPANY
IN COVINA AND VARIOUS
SUPERMARKETS IN WINE AND SPIRIT
LOCAL BUSINESSES.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL DO
OUR PART TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
WINE TO INCREASE ITS
COMPETITIVENESS IN THE WORLD
MARKET AND TO CONTINUE
GENERATING ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REAL REQUESTER AYE VOTE ON
EASIER TO ONLY.
AUTHORED BY MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE FROM WINTERS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I THINK THE MEMBER FROM WINTERS
FOR BRINGING FOR THIS
RESOLUTIONS VERY STRONGLY
SUPPORT IT. NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR THAT THE WINE INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA CONTRIBUTES TO THE U.
S. ECONOMY BUT ALSO BECAUSE I
REPRESENT THE OLDEST Y. GRAPE
GROWING REGION IN THE STATE
LIVERMORE VALLEY. WHERE SEVENTY
PERCENT? OF SKIS ME EIGHTY
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA CHARDONNAY
VINES TRACE THEIR ROOTS TO
LIVERMORE VALLEY STOCK. AND
THEY'VE BEEN GROWING WINE GRAPES
AND AND HAVE OVER.
FIFTY WINERIES IN LIVERMORE
VALLEY AND THEY'VE BEEN DOING
THIS SINCE THE EIGHTEEN FORTIES
YOU DON'T DO THAT IF YOU ARE NOT
SOMEONE WHO TAKES CARE OF THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND WATER CONSERVATION AND THE
BEST POSSIBLE STEWARD YOU COULD
BE OF YOUR LANDS AND WINE GRAPE
GROWING REGIONS ARE ALSO
TERRIFIC EXAMPLES OF HOW YOU CAN
HAVE CONSERVATION EASEMENTS THAT
PROTECT AGRICULTURAL LAND. AND
ALL THE JOBS THAT COME FROM THAT
IN MY DISTRICT ALONE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR OF ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY. IS GENERATED FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
COUNTRY AND SO THIS IS A REGION
WERE CELEBRATING AND COLLEAGUES
THEY'RE GOING TO BE UNDER GREAT
GREAT THREAT.
IF THE TARIFFS THAT ARE
THREATENED.
ARE IMPLEMENTED.
ARE CALIFORNIA WINERIES ARE VERY
DEPENDENT ON TRADE.
IN THE PACIFIC RIM AND TO CHINA
AND COUNTRIES.
IN THE EASTERN PACIFIC RAM THIS
IS WHERE THEY CAN GROW AND WE
ARE NEEDING TO HAVE THEIR BACKS
TO MAKE SURE WE SUPPORT THEM
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THEY ARE GOOD
STEWARDS OF THE LAND. AND THEY
COME UP WITH A GREAT PRODUCT SO
VERY PROUD TO CO AUTHOR THIS AND
THINK THAT MEMBER FROM WINTERS
TO BRING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU CELL NUMBER WALDRON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR TO ALL EIGHT.
MY DISTRICT INCLUDES GREAT
VINEYARDS FROM FALL BURKE AND
BOND SOUL TO VALLEY CENTER.
TWO OF THE REGION KNOWN AS.
TO MECCA LA VALLEY I HAVE PARTS
OF THAT WONDERFUL TO MICHAEL
VALLEY WINE AREA.
ARE REGION'S FAVORABLE CLIMATE
AND SOIL CONDITIONS HAVE ALLOWED
VINES TO FLOURISH THERE SINCE
THE EIGHTEENTH CENTURY. WHEN IT
BECAME WELL KNOWN FOR THE
QUALITY OF ITS WINE.
THE SAN DIEGO AND SOUTHWEST
RIVERSIDE WINE SCENE IS RAPIDLY
GROWING AND IS A FAVORITE GET
AWAY FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS THE
WINES PRODUCED IN THIS REGION
ARE BOUGHT AND SOLD ALL AROUND
THE WORLD. AS A PROUD MEMBER OF
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
WINE.
I AM EXCITED TO BE SUPPORTING
THIS INITIATIVE AND TO
CONGRATULATE THE. THE WINERIES
THAT ONE THE GREEN METAL
YESTERDAY AND LEARNING ABOUT THE
SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES AND II YOU
ARE TONIGHT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF A CIGAR TO A.
CELEBRATING.
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS
CALIFORNIA WINDS DOWN TO EARTH
MONTH.
SUSTAINABILITY IS A VITAL PART
OF THE LONG TERM FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA WINE WHICH
CONTRIBUTES ESTIMATED FIFTY
SEVEN POINT SIX MILLION BILLION.
ANNUALLY IN ECONOMIC IMPACT TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
MORE THAN HALF OF CALIFORNIA
WINES ARE CERTIFIED IF
CALIFORNIA'S SUSTAINABLE IN FACT
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT LODI RULES
FOR SUSTAINABLE WINEGROWING FOR
MY DISTRICT.
CALIFORNIA'S ORIGINAL.
AVAILABLE VITICULTURE PROGRAM.
LOOK I'VE HONED OVER EIGHTY FIVE
WINERIES IN MORE THAN A HUNDRED
TEN THOUSAND ACRES OF WINE
GRAPES OF WHICH OVER TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND ACRES HAVE BEEN
CERTIFIED GREEN.
LITTLE EYES ALSO KNOWN AS
INFIDEL CAPITAL OF THE WORLD
IMPRISONS MORE WINE GRAYSON
NAPA.
DURING HARVEST SEASON WONDER
TRUCK TODAY TAKE LOOK LIKE
GRAPES TO NAPA.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CELEBRATE CALIFORNIA WINES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIVE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MERITS OF WHAT RECOGNIZING WINE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR CURRY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK MY OF
FELLOW MEMBERS FOR STANDING IN
RISING IN SUPPORT OF OUR ACR
TUESDAY TWO ZERO EIGHT TODAY.
.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE THE TIME
FOR AGRICULTURE IN THE
INNOVATION THAT OUR PEOPLE HAVE
DONE.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE A
HIGHLIGHT FOR ALL OF YOU TO COME
TO OUR WINE DISTRICTS TO SEE
WHAT AGRICULTURE IS REALLY DOING
SO I ASKED WITHOUT ASKING AYE
VOTE.
THIS MATTER QUIRK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS THIS IS.
OR CALL AUTHORS MEMBERS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
IT'S ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY SIX COOPER
IS ON THE MEASURE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A FORMER
COLLEAGUE ON THE FLOOR PLEASE
WELCOME. FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GEORGE RUNNER.
WE ARE RETURNING TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR CURRY FOR
HER GUEST INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS PART OF
DOWN TO EARTH MONTH CELEBRATION
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE SOME
SPECIAL GUESTS JOINING US UP IN
THE GALLERY.
STAND COME.
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE SELECT COMMITTEES
ONLINE RECOGNIZE SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA Y. COMMUNITIES
LEADERS FOR THEIR COMMITMENT TO
SUSTAINABLE. WINEGROWING
PRACTICES.
RYAN VOGEL AND ROB MCALLISTER
FROM VOCAL VINEYARDS A
CLARKSBURG WERE OR RECOGNIZE
FURTHER ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND
SOCIALLY EQUITABLE AND
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE WINEGROWING
PRACTICES.
NO WAY.
AND THEN WE HAVE A BIG HOLE OVER
AND MADELINE REFUTE CLOVER FROM
CAGEY VINEYARD MANAGEMENT LODI
WERE RECOGNIZE FOR USING
INNOVATIVE PRACTICES THAT
ENHANCE RELATIONS WITH EMPLOYEES
NEIGHBORS A COMMUNITIES.
AND WE ALSO HAVE REPRESENT US
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
SUSTAINABLE WINEGROWING
ALLIANCE.
THE LODI Y. ANGRY COMMISSION THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS AND THE WIND.
INSTITUTE PLEASE JOIN ME IN
GIVING THEM A WARM ASSEMBLY
WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SIXTY SEVEN
ACR TO TEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TO TEN BY SOMETHING
MEMBER FRAZIER RELATIVE TO
SPECIAL OLYMPICS DAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES TODAY ARE
PRESENT ACR TO TEN. WHICH
PROCLAIMS APRIL ELEVENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS SPECIAL OLYMPIC
STAYING CALIFORNIA.
SPECIAL LYMPICS IS THE WORLD'S
PREMIER SPORTS ORGANIZATION FOR
CHILDREN AND ADULTS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
EUNICE KENNEDY SHRIVER FOUNDED
THE ORGANIZATION AFTER
WITNESSING THE MISTREATMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH ID DE.
APART FROM THE STATE LEGISLATOR
WHAT LEGISLATURE.
SPECIAL OLYMPICS BROUGHT THE
POWER OF YOU UNIFIED SPORTS TO
OVER THREE HUNDRED NEW
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS THIS
YEAR.
THIS PROGRAM BRINGS TOGETHER
ATHLETES WITH AND WITHOUT
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES TO
TRAIN AND COMPETE ON THE SAME
TEAM.
ATHLETES BUILD FRIENDSHIPS
DEVELOP CHARACTER AND LEADERSHIP
AND.
DIGNITY AND SELF ESTEEM.
WITH ACR TO TEN WE RECOGNIZE THE
TREMENDOUS IMPACT THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS HAS ON COMMUNITIES
AROUND CALIFORNIA TO INSPIRE ALL
PEOPLE.
PHIL FULFILL THEIR GREATEST
POTENTIAL.
MADAM SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
IT WAS JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO
THAT YOU MET MY SISTER SHERRY.
AYE WITH DOWN SYNDROME WHO HAS
BENEFITED GREATLY GREATLY FROM
THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS THROUGHOUT
YEARS.
IT'S AT THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS
THAT THESE PARTICIPATOR SKIP TO
COME AND COMPETE IN SPORTS AND
THAT'S A GREAT THING BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT.
THEY ALSO GET.
TO.
BENEFIT FROM HEALTH SCREENINGS
SUCH AS I TESTING AND DENTAL AND
OTHER THINGS AND HAVE. AT TIMES
BEEN.
BEEN FOUND TO HAVE NEEDS THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN
NOTICED FOR POINTED OUT SO
SPECIAL OLYMPICS IS GREAT FOR
SPORTS INVOLVEMENT BUT IT'S ALSO
GREAT TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT.
THESE PARTICIPATOR ARE BEING.
HAVE HEALTH NEEDS ARE BEING MET
AT THE SAME TIME.
SO IT'S AN HONOR AGAIN TO
SUPPORT ACR TO TEN AND THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE FOR BRINGING FORWARD
TODAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I COULDN'T.
THE SPEAK HIGHLY ENOUGH OF THIS
GREAT INSTITUTION CALLED THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS.
I'M VERY VERY GRATEFUL TO OF
BEEN A SMALL PART EARLY IN MY
LIFE I WAS ABLE TO FORMULATE A
TEAM. OUT OF STATE
AND TO SEE THE IMPACT IT HAS ON
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS IS JUST SO
REMARKABLE IT WILL MAKE YOU A
BETTER PERSON TO GO AND ATTEND I
PROMISE YOU. SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS UP. TO THE FLOOR
TODAY AND PLEASE SHOW YOUR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS IN ANY WAY THAT
YOU CAN THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES MA'AM.
AS A VOLUNTEER FOR SPECIAL
OLYMPICS FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS.
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO WORK WITH
THIS ORGANIZATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST ROLE
HELD OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS YES
MA'AM.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE.
WHOLE AUTHORS
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CALL
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
BUT A CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN
COOPER'S ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER TO THE FOLLOWING BILL. TO
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
FIVE LACKEY FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE THE BILL
WAS REPORTED OUT OF BMP.
COMMITTEE INCORRECTLY RESPONSE
GO TO PUBLIC SAFETY THANK YOU
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MOVING TO ITEM OF SIXTY EIGHT HR
EIGHTY EIGHT MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SOME AMBER COLOR AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE SAKE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS EYES THE
FIRST INDIAN AMERICAN TO SERVE
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
IT BRINGS ME GREAT HONORED
INTRODUCED HR EIGHTY EIGHT.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ADA RECOGNIZES
THIS YEAR'S BY SAKE CELEBRATION
ON SATURDAY. APRIL FOURTEENTH
AND ENCOURAGES CALIFORNIANS TO
PARTICIPATE IN COMMUNITY BY SAKE
CELEBRATIONS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN ANCIENT FESTIVAL OF GREAT
SIGNIFICANCE TO SIX HINDUS AND
BUDDHISTS AND MANY REGIONS OF
INDIA. AND OTHER PARTS OF SOUTH
OF SOUTHEAST ASIA. BUT SAKE IS
CELEBRATED ANNUALLY. ANNUALLY ON
APRIL THIRTEENTH OR FOURTEENTH
BY MANY CALIFORNIANS WAS SICK IN
INDIAN HERITAGE.
BUT SAKE IS ALSO A LONG
ESTABLISHED HARVEST FESTIVAL TO
CELEBRATE THE AGRICULTURAL YEAR
AND PRAY FOR ABUNDANT RUGBY
PRODUCE A CROP PRODUCE. FOR THE
NEXT SEASON.
FOR SIX AND SICK AMERICANS BY
SAKE HOLD SPECIAL RELIGIOUS AND
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE.
BECAUSE IT COMMEMORATES THE
CREATION OF CASA AND INITIATED
THE FIVE KAY'S TRADITION OF THE
CALL SO THAT CONTINUES TO BE THE
BASIS. FOR THE UNIQUE SICK
IDENTITY WHEREBY SIX WORK CASH
UNCUT HERE. CONGA A WOODEN COMB
GOTTA AN IRON OR STEEL BRACELET
WORN ON THE WRIST GET UPON AN
ARTICLE OF FAITH TAKEN THE FORM
OF A SWORD. AND CUT JETTA SHORT
BRIDGES.
HR EIGHTY EIGHT OBSERVED BY SAKE
IS ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
DAYS WERE SICK AMERICANS ARE
SICK HISTORY AND EXPRESSES
CALIFORNIA'S DEEP RESPECT. FOR
ALL WHO OBSERVE AND CELEBRATE MY
SAKE THROUGHOUT THE WORLD ON
THIS OCCASION DURING THE COURSE
OF THIS WEEK AND IN THE
FOLLOWING WEEKEND THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MANY.
FESTIVALS AND PARADES AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING THERE ON THIS
SUNDAY IN STOCKTON AT THE OLDEST
CORD BLOOD A IN THE NATION. FOR
THEIR TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
MAGNETIC IT THEN AND PARADE.
I WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN AYE BOAT AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME BUT ASK UP THAT
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN
CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
JOINT COMMITTEE ON SPEAKER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR EIGHTY
EIGHT AS A CO AUTHOR. AND WOULD
I WANT TO WISH EVERYONE IN MY
DISTRICT UNHAPPY BUT SAKE.
THIS DIRE ANNUAL SPRING FESTIVAL
COMES WITH MANY COLORFUL EMBURY
FUN TRADITION.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CELEBRATING IN
MY DISTRICT AND ENCOURAGE ALL OF
YOU TO DO THE SAME MEAN YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I ALSO RISE AS A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR OF HR EIGHTY EIGHT.
.
MISAKI IS A IT IS IT IS A GREAT
FESTIVAL CELEBRATED BY MANY OF
MY CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT
OF OF.
SEEK IN HINDU FAITH.
AS AS MAYBE MANY OF YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A VERY LARGE PUNJABI
AMERICAN.
CONTINGENT IN YUBA CITY AND THE
THE CENTER AREA AND IN MY
DISTRICT.
.
AND AS AS WAS POINTED OUT BY BY
THE AUTHOR AND. YOU KNOW IT'S A
CELEBRATION OF OF THE HARVEST
AND AS.
AS.
.
PEOPLE ARE NOW GOING OUT IN
PLANTING A GAY RAY TO PLANT FOR
THE YEAR. WE WON AN ABUNDANT
HARVEST TO COME AND THAT'S
THAT'S PART OF WHAT THIS.
THIS FESTIVAL IS ABOUT.
AND ALSO COMMEMORATED BY THE
SIKH FAITH AND.
AS AS WAS POINTED OUT BY MY BY
BY BY THE AUTHOR.
CELEBRATING CONGA AND AND AND
AND WHAT THAT MEANS TO TO THE
FACE SO. I JOIN.
.
MY OF MY CONSTITUENTS AS WE
RECOGNIZE MISAKI TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION IS.
OF THE MOST CELEBRATED EVENTS IN
THE C. CALENDAR. I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD.
AND DRAWING ATTENTION TO THIS
ARE HARVEST CELEBRATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON HR EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
IN SUPPORT. OF HR EIGHTY EIGHT
WHICH RECOGNIZES THIS YEAR'S THE
SHIKI CELEBRATION ON SATURDAY
APRIL FOURTEENTH.
THE CITY IS OF GREAT
SIGNIFICANCE TO SIKHS HINDUS AND
BUDDHISTS
CELEBRATED BY MANY CALIFORNIANS.
IT MARKS THE NEW YEAR AND ALSO
COMMEMORATES.
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE YOUR SIKHISM
WAS BORN IS A COLLECTIVE FAITH
IS ALSO A HARVEST FESTIVAL THAT
CELEBRATES THE NEW A CULTURAL
YEAR. IT DISPENSED PAY FOR CROP.
PRODUCE THE NEXT SEASON.
IF THE PROTOCOL AUTHOR THIS
MEASURE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON YOUR RECORDS THANK
YOU.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AYE AYE TO
RISE OUT.
THE IN HONOR OF THIS VERY OFTEN
IMPORTANT DAY.
.
LAST YEAR I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
OF BEING INVITED BY OUR.
MEMBERS OF THE SIKH COMMUNITY
DURING A TURBINE A CELEBRATION.
AND I GOT TURBAN.
I WILL TELL YOU IT IS A REAL
HONOR I ACTUALLY LOOKED PRETTY
COOL IN A TURBAN.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW IF YOU GET AN
OPPORTUNITY.
IF YOU GET ON OPPORTUNITY. BY
THE WAY THE TURBAN OUR. I GENTLY
TOOK OFF MY AND I HAVE IT. UP
NOW IN MY OFFICE ON A.
BUST OF PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN
SO.
A IT WAS A WONDERFUL HONOR IF
YOU EVER GET A CHANCE NOT ONLY.
YOU GET TO LEARN WHAT THAT MEANS
AND WHAT THE TURBAN IN A
SIGNIFIES IN THE CARE PAN ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS SO. I
NEVER GOT A CHANCE TO DO IT A DO
IT AND TO ALL OF OUR. A C.
CONSTITUENTS IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WE TREASURE YOU WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR WHAT YOU DO AND
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THIS A
CELEBRATION FOR WHAT IT MEANS TO
HARVEST AND WHAT IT MEANS TO
YOUR CULTURE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER KALRA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THANK
YOU.
TO MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES ARE
CLEARLY A.
YOU HAVE GREAT KNOWLEDGE AND
RESPECT FOR MY SAKE AND I
APPRECIATE IT AND.
AS TWO OF MY COLLEAGUES MOST
RECENT COMMENTS YOU WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT A TURBAN ON
TODAY.
THERE IS A RECEPTION FROM
ELEVEN TO TWO DIED TO TWELVE
THIRTY ROOM ONE TWENTY FIVE
TODAY IS TURBINE DAY.
IN THE STATE CAPITOL AND I'LL
SPEAK OF THE TO THAT IN AYE AYE
MY INTRODUCTION OF SOME OF THE
GUESTS HERE ABOUT WHAT THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT AND
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE FIRST
WILL OPEN. BURKE CO AUTHORS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. ISRAEL WAS FOR
COFFERS MEMBERS.
THIS ROLES RECALL AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS RECALL AUTHORS ON
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE. THERE ARE SIXTYFIVE POLL
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM. ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MISTER
KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AND I'M HAPPY TO INTRODUCE A
GAS THAT WE HAVE HERE TODAY FROM
THE JOYOUS SAIBA. NATIONAL SEE
CAMPAIGN MY HOME GOOD WHILE THE
SOUNDS AGO BONTA. AS WELL AS
SACRAMENTO SIX THEY'RE ALL
JOINING TOGETHER TO HOST TURBINE
DAY HERE AT THE CAPITOL BIGGEST
AND UP WHOEVER'S HERE FOR THE
RESOLUTION SERVICE DAY.
SO.
SO PLEASE. PLEASE JOIN US FOR
THOSE THAT ARE HEADING OUT OF
TOWN.
RECESSION GO BACK YOUR DISTRICTS
ELEVEN TO TWELVE THIRTY SO
HOPEFULLY I'LL HAVE TIME TO STOP
BY YOUR STAFFS ARE CERTAINLY
WELCOME YOUR STOP. ALL YOUR STOP
MEMBERS AND OTHER IS GOING TO BE
TURPENTINE ARTIST OF THE FOOD
THERE'S A LOT MORE YOU CAN LEARN
ABOUT THE SIX FEET THE TRADITION
AND ABOUT BY SAKE SIR THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. MISTER FRAZIER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY
JOINING ME IN THE GALLERY. WE
HAS FROM GUESTS FROM A VERY
SPECIAL GUEST FROM THE US
SPECIAL LEVEES.
PLEASE HELP ME COLLEAGUES GIVE
THEM A VERY WARM WELCOME
.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SIXTY NINE HR
NINETY MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETY BY
SELLING MEMBER MCCARTY RELATIVE
TO TELL EDUCATION WEEK.
THANK YOU A SUMMER MCCARTY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT HR NINETY RECOGNIZING
THIS WEEK APRIL EIGHTH TO THE
FOURTEENTH AS ADULT EDUCATION WE
IN CALIFORNIA. WE ALL KNOW ABOUT
THE DOLT AT ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS
WE KNOW THAT IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WE HAVE TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS
AND STAFF WORKING TIRELESSLY TO
BRING LIFE CHANGING. EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES TO OUR ADULT ED
STUDENTS WHO ARE SEEKING HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR GED
CERTIFICATE BASIC READING
SKILLS.
ENGLISH LITERACY ARE FOCUSING ON
THEIR CITIZENSHIP CLASSES.
I KNOW ABOUT THIS ISSUE FIRST
HAND.
I AM ADULT EDUCATION.
I SWEAR I SERVE WITH YOU TODAY
HAVE A COLLEAGUE IN THE ASSEMBLY
WITH THAT TO POST SECONDARY. AYE
DEGREES BUT. AFTER A LACKLUSTER
HIGH SCHOOL CAREER I ACTUALLY
WENT TO AN ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM RIGHT DOWN THE STREET
HERE TO RECEIVE MY HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA. AS DID MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE EAST LOS ANGELES SHE
SHARED HER SIMILAR EXPERIENCE OF
ADULT EDUCATION SERVES I MANY IN
OUR IN OUR STATE WE KNOW ABOUT
THIS. FIRST HAND IN THE STATE
BUDGET AND IN THE. MID TWO
THOUSAND BEFORE THE RECESSION.
ARCADE TWELVE SYSTEM HAD HAD.
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FUND IT FOR OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION STUDENTS UNFORTUNATE
TODAY WE ONLY FIND ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION SERVING FEWER
STUDENTS THE NEED. IS TREMENDOUS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA POPOLI WEEK
HOPEFULLY WE CAN ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE THIS YEAR AND IN THE YEARS
TO COME. SO I WOULD ASK THAT ALL
OF US JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING HR
NINETY RECOGNIZING ADULT
EDUCATION WEEK. I ALSO ASK THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEADOW QUIRK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE THIS ROLL-ON HOA
OFFERS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM. ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
I AM SEVEN D. THROUGH SEVENTY TO
PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM SEVENTY THREE A. B. TWENTY
NINETY MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND ACTUALLY THE
GUARDIANSHIP.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
FEDERAL LAW ALLOWS THE PERSON
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE TO
APPLY FOR LEGAL PERMANENT
RESIDENCY IF THEY'RE GRANTED
SPECIAL IMMIGRATION JUVENILE
STATUS OR AS I J. S..
FEDERAL LAW ALSO SPECIFIES THAT
A YOUTH IS AGILE ELIGIBLE FOR AS
AYE JAYE AS IF REUNIFICATION
WITH ONE OR BOTH OF THE CHILD'S
PARENTS IS NOT A VIABLE OPTION.
DUE TO ABUSE OR NEGLECT.
SITUATION IS POSSIBLE AND
FREQUENT WHICH A NON ABUSIVE
PARENT IS IN THE UNITED STATES
AND THE ABUSIVE PARENT IS IN THE
COUNTRY OF ORIGIN.
WITHOUT THE PROTECTION OF SIG AS
THE CHILD.
COULD ESSENTIALLY BE DEPORTED TO
THE ABUSIVE PARENT.
TO PREVENT THIS TRAGEDY AND
ALLOW A CHILD TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE STATUS AB TWENTY NINETY
ADDS THE WORD PARENT TO EXISTING
STATE STATUS SO THAT THE STATE
COURTS COULD APPOINT A PARENT AS
A GUARDIAN FOR THE LIMITED
PURPOSE APPLYING FOR THIS
STATUS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED NOT A HAS NOT
RECEIVED A SINGLE NO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROAD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY ONE
NO ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR THROUGH
SEVENTY EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING NOW TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING HER NONE WE WILL TO
FURTHER READING OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR UNTIL AFTER THE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SOMETHING WILL TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
BY SOMETHING MEMBER KALRA
ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE ON THE CONSENT.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE.
SIXTY SIX I KNOW ZERO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS A SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS APRIL THIRTEENTH NO
FLOOR SESSION NO CHECK IN
SESSION.
APRIL SIXTEENTH FLOOR SESSION AT
ONE PM.
THEIR WILL BE A RECEPTION FOR
DELORES HEARD TO UPON OF GERMAN
IN ROOM THREE SEVENTEEN.
AND THE ABSENCE OF A DROP OF
OBJECTION A QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED WEWILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON THE GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO*
BODY TO ADJOURN. IN THE MEMORY
OF SARAH CHISHOLM.
A SPIRITUALISM WAS BORN JULY
NINTH NINETEEN THIRTY IN TEXAS
BEFORE RELOCATING TO CHICAGO AND
THEN LATER SETTLING.
IN SUNNY CALIFORNIA SHE WORK
FOR THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
SUCCESSES OFFICE WHERE SHE SPENT
NEARLY OF OVER TWENTY FIVE PLUS
YEARS OF WORK FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ASSESSOR'S
OFFICE.
SARAH CHOOSE THEM WAS MY COUSIN
SHE WAS MY FATHER'S A FIRST
COUSIN AND SHE INSISTED WAS
GROWING UP TO CALL HER ON
SIERRA.
SHE WAS.
LIKE AND OUGHT TO OF MY ENTIRE
FAMILY MY SISTERS MYSELF I'M SHE
PASSED AWAY AT OUR HOME FROM A
LONG TERM ILLNESS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
STANDS OUT IN MY MEMORY AND ALSO
AT THE MEMORIAL SERVICE AND
EVERYONE ELSE MEMORIES WAS HER
VOICE HOW SHE CAN SING. AND OF
TO BEING AFRICAN AMERICAN SING
OPERA AND BEING ABLE TO HAVE A
VERY HIGH PITCH.
WITHOUT A MICROPHONE IS VERY A
REMARKABLE AND SHE WILL BE
MISSED AND I WAS CERTAINLY*
BODY TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
SIERRA. A CHISHOLM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
TO THE DEATH TO BE PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUEST TO RETURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASS RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISTER
GIPSON SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
APRIL SIXTEENTH AT ONE PM.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN.
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO A CYNICAL
TWENTY FOUR NINETY FIVE. I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN
THE SIX I SIXTY SIX KNOWS IF I'M
ABLE EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE BY
SIXTY SIX KNOWS ILLEGAL NINETEEN
OH NINE I SIXTY SIX KNOWS HERE I
WILL NINETEEN TWENTY. I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO UNABLE NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO FINAL NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
BY SIXTY SIX NO ZERO LEVEL
TWENTY FIFTY TWO I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO LEVEL TWENTY SIXTY TWO I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO A SINGLE
TWENTY EIGHTY I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO. A SOME EVIL TWENTY EIGHTY
EIGHT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SUM IT
ALL TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO LABEL TWENTY ONE
SIXTY NINE I SIXTY SIX KNOWS
YOU'RE A SINGLE TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
ZERO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN. AYE SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO SOME EVIL TWENTY NINE
HUNDRED I SIXTY SIX KNOWS ZERO
LIMITS TWENTY NINE OH TO AYE
SIXTIES
IT'S NO ZERO SINGLE TWENTY OH
NINE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO FINAL
TWENTY ONE SIXTY THREE I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO SIMILAR NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX I SIXTY SIX. NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FIFTY THREE I SIXTY SIX